[Music]
there's a Nancy Callahan action figures
out there that they manufacture I think
we have picture of wine and it's quite a
sexy part I'm looking at me when I think
action figures I think it's for the kids
right and then you think who's running
you know no kids supposed to have that
action figure it's it's a little
inappropriate yeah yeah I I think this
is an adult action figure I know like
three guys on my staff who will have
that yeah I've had a few I had my first
one was a Dark Angel one and then my
second was Fantastic Four
Wow okay and the first thing City and
then this one that's cool do you
actually collect them your own action
figures I have them in storage right
it's weird to have them I think around
the house it can look like you're insane
I do feel like I'm here but there's four
of me here it could look a little crazy
I feel a little weird but if I had four
action figures I'd have them all on
display I'd make one the hood ornament
on my car
you